[Music]
I'm I'm Rosalyn Williams and I want to
welcome you to the third colloquium
session how do history in memory shape
each other I hear it is a beautiful
Saturday morning and and yet we're
starting off on a serious if not almost
a somber theme but this is an
anniversary celebration and this session
is a reflection upon the meaning of such
remembrances and in in discussing this
session ahead of time which I had the
pleasure of doing with John and Pauline
Gillian was the last unavailable but the
three of us talked quite a bit and and
we thought about the meaning of 50th
anniversaries and came to realize that
50 50th celebrations are very special
because that's the moment when personal
biography becomes or begins to become
transformed into the public record with
awareness of our own mortality comes
awareness that there is a larger
collective story so what is that story
and who was going to tell that story
every year at commencement we see this
here at MIT when the students who are
graduating and I'm speaking here
especially the undergraduate students
are all wind-up and filing into Killian
court before they get to the court
there's always a moment and exactly how
the moment happens depends upon the
logistics of commencement that year but
there's a moment where the
graduates confront the 50th reunion
class and it's it's a it's a moment of
great poignancy because the 50th year
alumni are looking at the students and
they're seeing themselves and the
students are looking at the alumni and
they're seeing themselves and and that's
a moment when history almost becomes
visible it becomes palpable it's it's as
I say a very poignant moment and I think
we here today are engaged in a similar
moment in modern times and by this I
mean particularly in the 19th century
the composition of the personal past
personal memory got more and more
attention I don't you know Freud is the
obvious person but Proust many other
artists were giving a lot of attention
to the personal past but the historical
past began to lose as much of its
authority so by the beginning of the
20th century in many levels of culture
there was a prevailing assumption that
societies could and should shed what was
often called the burden of the past and
if he can't recollect the details of the
futurist manifesto right now but I
remember this line of Marinette ease
about you know racing car being more
beautiful than the Parthenon and one of
his Co future is saying that the most
essential artists of our times is fire
they wanted to get rid of the past at
mid century however the mid 20th century
when the school was founded the burden
of the past never seemed heavier because
in the preceding decades there had been
human losses that were incomprehensible
there had been much too much fire MIT of
course was deeply engaged in both of the
wars and in in that whole history of
loss in the early 20th century efforts
to come to terms with those losses both
individually and collective
we led to conflicting responses in the
post-war period a determination never to
forget but also a desire not to remember
and what one society wanted to forget
and remember was often different from
what another society wanted to and I
think we are still living with this
cultural ambivalence we're surrounded by
historical amnesia on the one hand and
on the other by an obsession with
oversimplified historical myths
we're also subjected increasingly to
somewhat in parallel to what Steve
Pinker was talking about yesterday is an
implicit theory of human nature I think
we're surrounded by an implicit theory
of history which is this rhetoric of
change management that equates history
with technology and change with the
latest software upgrade we were
exchanging the burden of the past for a
burden of this perpetual change the
burden of the future real change real
change historical change is far more
difficult far more upsetting than a
technological upgrade is closer to what
Louise glook was describing in her poem
yesterday about the cottonmouth it's
more like rebirth having to to start a
new life and it's a hard thing but
that's historical change the panelists
here today are going to reflect upon the
complex relationships among between myth
and history and between remembering and
forgetting and they're going to speak in
roughly chronological order
Pauline Mayer is based in the 18th
century Dame Gillian beer the 19th at
John dower in the 20th but by the end of
the session we will discover that this
is a very simplistic way of describing
any of them by the way the discussion
that follows we hope to have a
note of what I think it was Pauline
called substantive informality and so
please keep that in mind while you're
listening to them for your part in the
discussion I would call your attention
to the bibliographical summaries in the
program because I will not be repeating
them but I really want to make sure you
do read them and then I'll just add a
few words about each of the speakers in
introducing Pauline well I've been
discussing this session at home with my
family because it's been fun to get
ready for it and so last week my son
came home and he's a junior at Newton
North High School and he said he had
seen Pauline in class on TV it was the
PBS show or one on one of their series
on the American Revolution and I this is
a reminder to me and to you both how
much of Pauline's work has involved well
I was trying to find the words because
we call it public outreach it just
sounds a little but now I'd like to
think of what Pauline has done as acts
of citizenship in the spirit of the
formative years of our republic that she
has herself studied and it's also a
reminder it's not just physics at MIT
that has influenced national education
in history also just to take what
Pauline has done she's involved with
other TV programs on the History Channel
and with PBS she has written a textbook
in American history for the junior high
level
she is co-authoring another textbook
funded by the sloan foundation that is
going to give a prominent place to the
history of science and technology and
Roe Smith another MIT faculty members
also a collaborator in that project and
when Pauline's book American Scripture
was published on July 4th 1997 it was so
you were hot MIT was hot it was
wonderful every day there was news and
and you know the publicity was just
great and we all felt such shared pride
in that event in that book and elsewhere
Pauline is not exam is examining not
only the making of the Declaration of
Independence but what it is meant to
subsequent generations how this
revolutionary manifesto became a guide
to established governments and in terms
of governance I also want to conclude by
mentioning that Pauline has had a
leading role in the governance of this
school and a leading role in the history
of this school when she arrived here the
next year she became head of the history
department was head for eight years nine
years and also during the mid-1980s
chaired the committee that reformed the
teaching of the humanities here at MIT
that's when I first encountered Pauline
she was came in with these committee
meetings ran the meetings she knew
everything she was so knowledgeable and
so thoughtful and I was in awe of her
and I still am thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Roz after an introduction like
that I think what I should do is just
leave it's only down downhill from here
I should also explain to haven't been
around very much because I have my own
private experience of the passage of
time I have been attending my fortieth
college reunion of Harvard Radcliffe
which will explain any lapses of
coherence in this talk and the left you
know the bags under my eyes etc our
assignment here as I understand it is to
reflect on the complex relationship of
memory myth and history many of you are
aware that there is now a vast
literature that focuses on this topic
some of it produced by another member of
my household as I understand it and I
don't pretend to be an expert we have a
division of labor in my household is
that that literature focuses to a good
bit to a good extent on collective
memory that is and how groups assume an
identity by defining constructing as the
preferred verb seems to be a view of the
past several decades after the events
that are described occurred my own
reflections are for better for worse
somewhat different I do have some
interest in collective memory as you'll
see but I'm going to focus much more on
individual memory and my comments are
much more I think personal than
theoretical what insights I have to
offer come from an event I witnessed and
another that I studied at Harvard's
commencement in June 1947 Secretary of
State George Marshall announced what
became the Marshall Plan a program of
massive economic aid to war-torn Europe
designed to reestablish in his words
political and social conditions in which
free institutions can exist to
commemorate the 50th anniversary of that
momentous event
Harvard organized
Volk wium in the spring of 1997 invited
ten or twelve men who in one capacity or
another had participated in the plan
along with a handful of historians who'd
studied the Marshall Plan and its impact
from my perspective in one of the back
rows at the Harvard Science Center the
event soon came to seem less like a
colloquium than a revival as one
old-timer after another rose to testify
confident that perhaps because he was
after all at Harvard and what he said
would become part of the historical
record and indeed would set the record
straight they spoke to particular
specialized points that often were to
someone like me who does not closely
follow the the debates over post-war
history more bewildering than
informative the speakers were however
obviously antagonistic toward one of the
participating historians Alan Millward
who I later learned had questioned the
Marshall plans impact that explain the
emotional character of the proceedings
these veterans of more glorious days
were reaffirming the significance of
their service they were reclaiming their
place in history from the professionals
who were taking it away as I witnessed
the drama it crossed my mind that I was
about to publish American Scripture
which offered the history of a far
simpler event the drafting of the
Declaration of Independence and and a
good deal of the testimony upon the
evolution of the Declaration of
Independence I testable testimony upon
which historians have relied was given
almost 50 years after the drafting had
been done and in the course of my
research I discovered that on point
after point that testimony was incorrect
so I wondered was it worth even trying
to get the message of those cept oh and
octogenarians waiting patiently or
impatiently for their turn at the
microphone and the story I studied myth
was also a component after the war of
1812 a new generation of Americans had
risen to power and it was anxious to
keep the memory of its revolutionary
fathers from being lost they made it
their mission to preserve and print the
documentary record of the Revolutionary
era many of which remained in private
hands and were becoming scattered and
lost meanwhile guns buttons and other
mementos of the Revolution were suddenly
being honored like religious objects and
the revolutionaries themselves assumed a
superhuman character to be sure that
tendency was apparent earlier in books
such as Mason Weems --is life of
Washington which was first published in
1804 and gave us the Cherry Tree story
and more to the point here a Washington
who had remarkable resemblance to both
Moses and Christ depending on what
passages you looked at I I'd like to
give you an example because it's rather
characteristic of the tendencies of the
time when Americans collective memory
was being defined I want to quote Weems
his version of Washington's death and
his shall we say ascent into heaven
breathing out father of mercies take me
to thyself he fell asleep Swift on
angel's wings the brightening Saint
ascended while voices more than human
were heard in fancies hear warbling
through the happy regions and hymning
the great procession toward the gates of
heaven his glorious coming was seen far
off in myriads of mighty angels hastened
forth with golden harps to welcome the
honored stranger hi in front of the
hosts were seeing the beauteous forms of
Franklin
Warren Mercer's gamal with all the
virtuous Patriots who on the side of
Columbia toiled or bled for liberty and
truth but oh how changed from what they
were when in the days of flesh bathed in
sweat and blood they fell at the parent
feet of their weeping country it's over
top right not all authors went that far
but this you know and this was part of
our response of the sort of the way the
member the Americans were coming to
remember and to honor their revolution
okay so occasionally the the record
didn't somehow fit the objectives of the
writers of the history and the dead
udders of documents in this era but they
could fix that Jared farc Oh Jared
sparks one of the leading writers and
editors of this period spent a good deal
of time sir probably suppressing a
rewriting passage it seemed too racy or
colloquial or in a word human even John
Adams graham son Charles Francis Adams
who I think is one of the most skilled
editors of that generation and and
conform more closely to modern editorial
standards than many of his
contemporaries refused to let his
cantankerous ancestor John Adams say
things such as he don't or you wasn't or
he eats strawberries or she ain't
obliged so what I'm here almost
literally the act of remembering changed
not just the past but the record of the
past we can fix the record of the past I
mean modern editorial projects they're
very nicely
you know restored the original language
but we still have those religious
overtones that were expressed and almost
grotesque their detail by Mason Weems
and if you doubt this visit the archives
the National Archives where our precious
national documents the Declaration of
Independence the the Constitution and
the Bill of Rights are displayed and
what can only be described as an altar
with the Declaration
where the tabernacle should have been
this is the period in fact where the
Declaration of Independence became a
national icon it had been saved from
obscurity in the 1790s by members of the
Republican Party who you know we're very
pleased their leader had written it they
said but in this period after the war of
1812 said the late teens and 20s it
became a national icon its first pretty
well its honored for one thing and that
famous painting by jonathan trouble
which Trumbull which is now in the
rotunda I think of the of the Capitol
the Declaration of Independence that
shows the committee essentially
presenting its draft to the Congress
it's often called the signing it's not
the signing lot of confusion about that
painting in any case its first printed
now it was printed of course for
distribution in 1776 but now you'd get
copies of the written version that was
signed and then in 1823 you had a
facsimile edition published the other I
brought my book along it gives me
confidence but the cover has has you
know in the background the written
version of the Declaration of
Independence we know what it looks like
but nobody aside from a few who could
pull it out of the drawers in the
Department of State knew what the
handwritten version looked like before
1823 when the facsimile was published
what had been distributed was of course
a printed version earlier on and it
becomes a national icon as I say it had
never as it had never been before and we
are very beholden actually as historians
to the Americans of that era who were
very anxious that that no more
revolutionaries would go to their grave
with unrecorded memories so they went
out and they asked questions that what
is surprising to us I think no one had
bothered to ask before such as how is
this document written
as it happens however of course far
fewer persons were involved in drafting
editing and adopting the Declaration of
Independence than in creating and
administering the Marshall Plan and life
was shorter in the 1820s than in the
late 20th century as a result of the
five people who had been on the
committee that drafted the Declaration
of Independence only two remained to
tell the story John Adams and Thomas
Jefferson neither neither of these men
had to face an Allen mill word that is a
historian to question the significance
of what they did
that doesn't mean they liked the
histories being written in their time
John Adams as cantankerous as I said
hated them
he said they distorted the people he had
known in life beyond all recognition
this is the point where you're getting
all these art affiliate patristic
biographies coming out Weems
we mice's tendencies replicated and in
the biography of one revolutionary after
another
he said the ideal the idolization of
Washington and other revolutionaries
reminded him of the canonization of
Catholic saints and John Adams was a
good old Puritan to the very end so that
wasn't something he was going to accept
the country needed he said a second
Protestant Reformation these heroic
histories he feared would traumatize the
young by giving them impossible models
to imitate in 1811 Adams confessed a
very great secret to a younger American
and you have to love him for this as far
as I am capable of comparing the merits
of different periods he said I have no
reason to believe we were better than
you are and on top of all these problems
the histories of the late eighteen tens
and 1820s emphasized the wrong events
can you believe they gave great impact
to the announcement of independence
not to independence itself and as a
result they were giving honor to the
wrong people the record clearly needed
to be corrected and Adams was ready in
August 1822 when Timothy Pickering wrote
him asking for a menu detail of facts
concerning the Declaration of
Independence which for Pickering and so
many others had become the most
important act of the Second Continental
Congress a detailed history would not it
would be not merely an interest in
curiosity Pickering said but would do
substantial justice to the abilities and
Entering energies of the leaders in that
great measure and he told Adams you
alone can give a full statement of them
now Adams was a few months short of his
87th birthday at the time and he said
I'm utterly incapable of complying with
your request and then he promptly wrote
several pages in reply giving her out
what anybody standard a very long letter
he'd give he had just received a chance
like those veterans at the Marshall Plan
at Harvard to set the record straight
I was incessantly employed he wrote
through the whole fall winter and spring
of 1775 and 1776 in Congress during
their sittings and on committees on
mornings and evenings and unquestionably
did more business than any other member
of the House actually I think that's
right going through the records and ever
actually Thomas Jefferson affirmed that
no one had argued and worked not that
Jefferson was there to witness that's
another story no one had argued and
worked for independence longer or more
strenuously than Adams Thomas Jefferson
who by the summer of 1776 had been about
a year a member of Congress but it
attended his duty in the house but a
very small part of the time and when
there had never spoken in public
nonetheless as Adams complained in an
earlier letter Jefferson had run off
with all the glory it was even more
annoying Thomas Paine was saying he
was exclusively responsible for
Independence pain Adams execrated pain
but Jefferson was a friend they had
resumed their friendship as you know
their wonderful set of correspondence
between Adams and Jefferson in their old
age and and that made him sensitive he
wasn't really unkind to his friend
Thomas Jefferson despite his sporadic
congressional service Jefferson had V
Adams volunteered a happy talent of
composition as a result Adams had urged
his appointment to the drafting
committee indeed he claimed the
committee actually asked both Adams and
Jefferson to prepare a draft declaration
but then he Adams had persuaded
Jefferson to write it up and his account
is often cited and I want I won't fight
off the temptation you should do it I
said Oh No
why will you not reasons enough I guess
there was Jefferson telling Adams you
should do it why shouldn't I do
why shouldn't Adams do it first you are
a Virginian and a Virginian ought to
appear at the head of this business
reason second
I am obnoxious this is Adams I am
obnoxious suspected and unpopular you
are very much otherwise reason third you
can write ten times better than I can
well said Jefferson if you are decided I
will do as well as I can
much of what Adams said also appeared in
his autobiography which he wrote 15 or
so years earlier but the notion that the
drafting committee had appointed both
Adams and Jefferson as draftsman was new
and very suspect was Adams trying to get
to run off with at least some of the
glory now turned to Jefferson Jefferson
a very different attitude toward the
history is being written in his time he
it seems this always was surprising to
me you think of him as such a you know a
secular enlightenment figure he loved
all this religious glop you know he in
fact the the Trumbull painting had first
been drafted under at first Trumbull had
made his first painting of the
Declaration of Independence in the late
1780s on
Jefferson's suggestion he had actually
sketched for Trumbull the hall where the
dark weather the Second Continental
Congress had met
it's almost emblematic because later
Trumbull discovered that Jefferson's
sketch was wrong he'd remembered it
incorrectly a first clue that that
memory is is very flawed as Jefferson
himself understood as you see in a
minute
and if part of the religious business
you know he he gave to his his grant
would his grandson in law I guess Joseph
Coolidge the desk on which he'd written
the Declaration of Independence which he
said he had written the Declaration and
he predicted that in another 50 years it
will be carried in processions like the
relics of saints he had no doubt about
he had no reservations about everything
that atoms so execrated but so we didn't
object to the historian to the histories
but he did abject to Adams account which
Pickering had used in the 4th of July
oration that was subsequently printed
and came to Jefferson's attention in
several details Jefferson wrote James
Madison an often quoted letter of August
30th 1823 Adams his memory was mistaken
he gave Adams full credit for his role
in getting independence through the
Congress still at the age of 88 here he
was off a little bit too and 47 years
after the transactions of Independence
Jefferson said that Adams should
remember some things in exactly did not
seem altogether surprising memory he
said was unreliable
now at the time Jefferson was himself 80
but he said he wasn't depending on
memory he had written notes on
Congress's proceedings taken by myself
at the moment on the spot and reduced to
a final form on the conclusion he also
had the original rough draft of the
Declaration an extraordinarily valuable
text now at the Library of Congress that
shows the draft as Jefferson first
presented it to other members of the
drafting committee and all subsequent
changes in fact Jefferson was so
confident that he had the sources on the
history that interested people they
he kept getting inquiries from people
and he wrote back even if he need to go
through his documents he wrote some
1,200 letters in 1820 by his own account
now think of the labor of this
handwritten letters many of which dealt
with historical events he felt great
responsibility
for getting the record straight but in
fact he was relying on memory much more
than he understood and but I want to
focus just on this one event of how it
was how the Commission gave it with the
account he gave of the drafting of the
Declaration the drafting committee asked
Jefferson alone to prepare the
Declaration he said I consented I drew
it
before I reported it to the committee I
commuted it it I communicated it
separately to dr. Franklin and mr. Adams
and he reminded Jefferson Madison you
have seen the original paper now in my
hands with the corrections of dr.
Franklin and mr. Adams interlined in
their own handwriting's their
alterations were two or three only and
merely verbal I then wrote a fair copy
reported it to the committee and from
then on altered to Congress well
unfortunately he well fortunately I
should say he he gave contrary evidence
himself in a letter that I discovered I
can't say it was very very hard it was
printed in a couple versions but nobody
had used it a letter he wrote to
Franklin and note they were sending the
draft to Franklin who had gout to look
at it and send it back he never attended
their drafting committee I was a member
of the drafting committee and it
basically he said I've just shown this
to the committee they asked me to change
a sentiment or two I have done it I hope
you can look at it and get it back to me
the next morning I have to show it to
the committee again the committee wasn't
a rubber stamp as he thought fifty years
later it was active and also I think I
understand why he thought he was
exclusively responsible honestly thought
in you know almost fifty years
afterwards the original rough draft is a
very complicated event to enter a to
interpret he looked
and he saw not only the draft but all
the changes with the exception of a few
that were clearly by Adams or Franklin
were in his handwriting I presume he
then assumed that he was responsible for
them what he forgot was that some of
them had been mandated by the committee
and there are other reasons I mean
there's that's one of many pieces of
evidence that indicate that although
Jefferson was obviously the primary
writer of the Declaration many hands fed
into its composition that he wasn't
exclusively responsible for it in fact
it's very curious that he was so anxious
to emphasize that he had been as he put
on his tomb author of the Declaration of
Independence you know that he put three
things on his tomb authored the
Declaration of Independence Father to
the University of Virginia and author of
the Virginia statute of religious
liberty it's surprising because at the
time the document was an enormous
humiliation to him Congress took up the
draft that the committee presented and
slashed it to bits they edit it they
took out 1/4 to 1/3 of the text they
changed phrases they threw out the parts
that Jefferson was most proud of they
changed the whole last paragraph
although the final version is on the
Jefferson Memorial and Jefferson gets
the glory for it he didn't even write
most of us on the Jefferson Memorial but
he was so humiliated by what Congress
did to his work that he wrote sent
several copies of the committee draft to
friends to see how Congress had mocked
it up and now near the end of his life
he goes back to this it's the first
thing that he emphasizes what we don't
understand is how much I think by the
1820s Jefferson feared for his place in
history he had no idea he was going to
come take it become take a deep breath
Thomas Jefferson you know the most
adored member of the founding generation
he looked over his life there was a
reason to be fearful you know we might
say he could say
American Minister governor of Virginia
American minister de France first
secretary of state vice president of the
United States and president maybe that'd
be enough you know this to us that's a
kind of an honor and he mentioned none
of his administrative career because in
fact it he had great reservations about
it his governorship of Virginia was a
disaster he left the capital of Virginia
with the British on his heels and was
later accused of cowardice nothing much
happened when he was in France the
Secretary of State was that he didn't do
anything he finally left because
Hamilton was running the state of
foreign affairs he didn't do anything as
vice president particularly went home
his presidency began gloriously and
ended in disaster with the midst of the
shambles of the embargo he couldn't wait
to get home to the quiet pleasures of
science as he put it not a fatty even
though we think of things like that you
know the Louisiana Purchase he couldn't
put that on his gravestone because I was
a wonderful thing my god he doubled the
size of the United States he did it
despite the fact his constitutional
principles it contradicted his
constitutional principles nothing that
Constitution said you could buy that
much of the continent and here he's
emphasizing he really worried about his
place in history and I think this is
relevant to the way we use these these
memories that are committed on paper so
long after the time if for one thing
they have errors that's true
but I think they're not their best not
treated as statements full of falsehoods
I like to think of the mix it is
expressing complex truths they tell us
something about the distant past but
they also tell us a tremendous amount
about the time in which those memories
are recorded and about the personal
circumstances of the individual who is
offering this testimony there very rich
sources and that's the way I tried to
use them but we go back to the fact that
these early versions had been absorbed
without an awful lot of reflection I
mean historians have used Jefferson's
account
the drafting as if it was perfectly
unproblematically but try you know try
contesting notions that have been so
deeply ingrained in our national myth
what I published American Scripture
people looked at it as an attack on
Thomas Jefferson which it wasn't I was
accused of saying he was a liar
well he wasn't consistent but I never
called him a liar
the other great thing was you know I
actually had the hood spot to say that
not everybody thought the second
paragraph of the Declaration of
Independence was the most important part
of the document at all times in our past
that in the founding generations they
actually prefer the last paragraph which
declares independence I mean this was my
not too surprising argument I guess at
the point of the Declaration of
Independence was to declare independence
and that the second paragraph came to
the fore later and I looked at the
historical context in which this
happened
forget it there are people that read
that paragraph and say that's really
that's so beautiful it must have been
beautiful at all times
to say people had other - you just
couldn't get through to that in fact
there was a point where I looked at some
of the reviews and and you know reviews
are often very sensitive I was just
talking to other members of the panel
you but those that were naked if I
started to realize I could distance
myself from them they worked really
about me or about my book they were
documents the way Americans were had
received their historical tradition and
how resistant they were to any
questioning of the myths that they had
received and I suppose of the of the
book tour I had there was a sense that
that lingers in my mind some woman in
Philadelphia said to me don't we need
these myths and maybe we do and I
suppose historians are always going to
be against them in some way we question
them we go back we try to compare the
documents to get a more accurate version
of what really happened and it doesn't
always lend itself to mythologizing
so we are always in some sense gonna be
antagonistic but you know I ultimately
came to the conclusion that truth was
more tonic than that in fact if you
looked at the drafting of the
Declaration you understood the extent to
which people had so many different
people had contributed to its creation
not just one great man but large numbers
those who produce the drafts
well hey drew George Mason wrote a
Virginia Declaration of Rights that in
fact Jefferson had used in drafting the
second paragraph members of the
committee who outlined the document
before had appointed a draftsman that
changes the committee suggest the
editing's of Congress and then
subsequent generations of Americans who
reinterpreted the document so that it
served their needs this was really Adams
this message that the creators of this
document were the American people and in
some ways I thought that was more
politically useful an idea certainly in
a country where the greater part of the
qualified adults don't see fit to vote
the example of immobilized people could
be extraordinarily healthy but that was
very hard to sell I mean who will holder
the myths and be very interesting to see
if the new display in the National
Archives still has an altar
[Applause]
Thank You Pauline I I know a lot of us
were thinking about the historical
record in the age of word processing and
it does change things I now have the
pleasure of introducing Dame Gillian
beer our visitor from England and I have
to say after this discussion of American
democracy our fascination with titles
indoors and you should also note that
she is King Edward the seventh professor
of English literature and and as Gillian
remarked offhandedly yesterday it's
sometimes hard to be Edward the seventh
but I think I want you to know that the
full title of her dame title is Dame
commander of the British Empire awarded
in 1998 as part of the Queen's Birthday
Honours List for and this is the best
part for services to English literature
and I you know that's an important
phrase it's you know the idea of serving
English literature I think is something
that it resonates with any of us in the
humanities it also though reminds us
that what Dame Gillian has done is to
broaden significantly the definition of
English literature her 1983 book
Darwin's plots which is subtitled
evolutionary narrative in Darwin George
Eliot and 19th century fiction is that
redefinition she took Darwin as a writer
as a writer who told stories who had a
structure who had a style and at the
same time took people we usually think
of as writers like Eliot and Hardy and
saw how they were drawing upon Darwin
we're using Darwin
if you will to tell their stories this
intertwining of Natural History in human
history is one of the defining
characteristics of our age of the modern
age the postmodern age I think both and
Dame Gillian veer is really a pioneer
for for doing this analysis that that
shows us how this has worked in our
culture I want to add a few notes to the
notes about her in the program she is a
trustee of the British Museum you should
also know she's been a Booker Prize
judge and chair of the panel this is
power and has served as vice president
and has served as vice president of the
British Academy but most notably I think
in the context he or she has
participated fully in the life of her
University are well I don't want to call
it a sister University Cambridge but
maybe cousin I'm looking at Larry back
at the right words and she has held the
Secession of offices within Cambridge
dating back to the 1970s including one
in the 1980s with the absolutely
delicious title of vice mistress of
Girton College
[Laughter]
these titles are just great now somewhat
more in a more pedestrian way she is
president of Clare Hall which is a
graduate college at Cambridge and she
tells me it was begun in the 1960s as
has heard a countercultural new style
college and I will just note in passing
how many educational experiments
including ones that MIT were started in
the later 60s and have lasted and
somebody should write a book about the
educational results of the 60s but
that's for another day anyway from what
she tells me it sounds delightful that
in quite contrary to our expectations of
a Cambridge College that there's no high
table she eats with the students 3/4 of
the students are from overseas and
there's a daycare center right on campus
so kids are always running around so
Dame you may be but you're very much at
home here and we welcome you
[Applause]
yes when I was given this title I asked
my friends whether I could be called a a
dame of British empiricism because it
seemed to me rather preferable to the
form of the Dame commander of the
British Empire but I was assured that
was not quite possible titles are very
odd things and one of the things I want
to look at this morning is the ways in
which if you like mythological
understanding of Charles Darwin has
ignored perhaps needed to ignore some
aspects of his work and to ask whether
those same aspects of his work that have
gone underground may be more disturbing
to us even than some of the things that
we sink we know frightened the
Victorians I think we're all used to the
idea that evolutionary theory threatened
consciousness in the Victorian period
and of course was continued to be
threatening to a good many people since
because it emphasized human kinship with
other life forms what Ruskin called the
filthy Harold ruse which record the
relation of the human to the acedia n--
and the crocodile
we used to to reading natural selection
as a theory of competition even in
herbert spencer's phrased as the
survival of the fittest and these are
our simplifications of Darwin whose
writing also offers a thoroughly
ecological extent let it be borne in
mind he says how infinitely complex and
close-fitting
are the mutual relations of all organic
beings to each other and to their
physical conditions of life one couldn't
have a more ecological statement than
that
nevertheless it's clear that for Darwin
there were a number of contrary energies
at work in his theory which could never
quite accommodate themselves to each
other and I want this morning to explore
particularly that voiding of human
memory from the explanatory system that
he was working out it seems to me that
this might be a sutler and longer
provocation yet than all those other
provocations and certainly one that has
resounded throughout the last hundred
and fifty years in the writing variously
of Proust and of Freud the attempt is
made to reach a total recuperation of
the individuals memory traces and for
Freud at least in civilization and its
discontents and Moses and monotheism
those traces he felt drew on the assumed
long buried histories of early humankind
and the pre-human
the problem of how to make a history
without invoking human eye witness seems
to have trouble Darwin and to have
provoked a recoil in his later writing
issues of organization habit awareness
and memory fascinate him from the start
of his career to its ending I like this
question he puts to himself in 1837
can insects live with no more
consciousness than our intestines have
it's a typically provocative question
from the young Darwin to himself raising
as it does not only the question of
insect intelligence but the question of
intestinal consciousness his
preoccupation with these issues of habit
awareness and memory surely must be the
more acute because his most famous work
and the origin of species in 1859 seeks
to make a history that both out goes and
for goes human memory as a shaping
presence that is his here writing
history that goes before and does
without human memory a world with no
human memory in it not yours not mine
not theirs indeed a world perhaps
without any memory in it at all
inhabited by instinctual creatures
possibly without what we would call
consciousness at the time that Darwin
started to write and when he was on the
voyage of the Beagle the whole issue of
natural history and whether it could
encompass the human was a very fraught
topic ethnography and anthropology were
just discovering themselves and the
assumption was that if the human could
end her natural history it would be the
human of the tribes most distant from
the writer and his kin so there was
already a sort of badinage around the
question of is the human part of a more
general history but he's wanting also to
describe something further two further
things he's wanting to describe
processes arrayed across enormous
intervals of time processes that will
leave shallow and fragmented records of
what he calls the mutations of life life
before beyond oblivious of the human and
for his argument to prevail he's got to
end
for sighs the absence of the human from
the most of the history of the earth and
also the difficulty that the human
imagination has in encompassing the vast
evidences of the past and the sickness
of the present he writes we continually
forget how large the world is we forget
that groups of species may elsewhere
have long existed we do not make do
allowance for the enormous intervals of
time which have probably elapsed between
our consecutive formations longer
perhaps in most cases than the time
required for the accumulation of each
formation Darwin here proposes our
forgetting we continually forget how
large the world is as if we had
previously known the largeness of the
world the enormous intervals of time but
of course at the same time he's making
it clear that we know these only as
constructed argument as interpreted
mementos and that is the nub of his own
particular Drive of argument he says we
falsely infer because certain general or
families have not been found beneath a
certain stage that they did not exist
before that stage reasoning it seems
produces a form of meta memory that may
be deeply unreliable because starved of
the beyond human a human materials that
are needed for true inquiry materials
that are always already lost forever
human memory has not inhabited these
vast tracts of former times no and this
is crucial nor can human memory help or
hinder the processes of natural
selection within the origin Darwin has
to elaborate a history apparently void
of consciousness and certainly void of
the power to change the future of the
natural world by any acts of remembering
and of course this is important to him
because he is insisting
the distance between what he's
describing and what Lamarck a little
earlier had described the possibility as
Lamarck sort of inheriting acquired
characteristics learning within the
lifespan of the creature the life-form
in such a way that those acquired
characteristics are then passed on to
the next generation there are times when
darwin vacillates on that question but
in the main the drive of what he's
arguing is that natural selection is the
accumulation of numerous successive
slight modifications I quote there I
think is no wonder then that at the same
time he is fascinated by the signs of
choice making among plants and simpler
organisms Darwin's career after the
publication of the Origin shows him
engaging with issues of conscious or
semi conscious selection sexual
selection the motions of climbing plants
the expression of the emotions in man
and the animals and in his last work the
formation of vegetable mould through the
action of worms and observations on
their habits he tells the history of the
world now through these lowly
inhabitants the mental powers and the
consciousness of worms become the focus
of his attention though his topic is the
formation of vegetable mould through
their action he says at one point as I
was led to keep in my study during many
months worms in pots filled with earth I
became interested in them and wished to
learn how far they acted consciously and
how much mental power they displayed as
usual he empathizes with his subjects he
engages them in his domestic life he
observes them with a kind of courtesy in
a manner both delicate and zealous and
at the start he has this desire
somewhere between intellect and
affection I became interested in them
worms he discovers are sensitive to
vibrations but and we can imagine the
experiment
that led to this formulation they're
indifferent to shrill whistles to
profound buffoons or to shouts as long
as care is taken that the best does not
strike them but if you put them on the
piano one worm dashed into its burrow on
a very high note being struck only once
and the other worm when see in the
treble clef was struck
these simple creatures as he says poorly
provided with sense organs yet seemed to
the observing Darwin to be capable of
discrimination choice and thus perhaps
even of memory he writes it is far more
surprising that they should apparently
exhibit some degree of intelligence
instead of a mere blind instinctive
impulse in their manner of plugging up
the mouths of their burrows they act in
nearly the same way as would a man
there's an area of uncertainty you see
here that has to do with both
consciousness and memory the two of
course are not the same but nevertheless
without consciousness it is I think
reasonable to assume that there cannot
be memory he's fascinated also by
instinct what he had earlier called
knowledge without experience a very good
summary way of putting instinct I think
knowledge without experience and in the
origin he's always struggling with this
question of consciousness memory
instinct a kind of triangle of
possibility and for instance in his
discussion of bees there's alarmingly
perfect architects perfect for a purpose
a single purpose as he puts it
economizing wax for bees no surplus
knowledge can be active and no memory
surfaces in these generations of
activity he writes the bees of course no
more knowing that they swept their
spheres at one particular distance from
each other than they know what are the
several angles are the hexagonal prisms
and of the basal rhombic plates
he deliberately introduces a discourse
from geometry to suggest the infinite
distance between the activity of the
bees and the fact that the bees don't
have the language the language they
can't not describe their own activity
but they come to have the actions and
that process of coming to have is
Darwin's narrative seem on the Origin of
Species by means of natural selection
it's a process not under the control of
memory in any organism perhaps not even
dormant within it and certainly not held
in trust by any human society Holland to
write the history of forms and beings
without memory how to write history
without or in the useful Scottish word
out with memory the effort he puts into
it is enormous and is accomplished in
part by evoking the present largeness of
the world its manifold physical variety
its disciplinary various nests it's
accomplished also by emphasising lack
and absence the impossibility of the
single forward interpretive act unknown
causes
he writes unknown laws of growth these
are made to be as much a part of the
argument as the emphasis on instances
and on close connections between
phenomena and of course remember Darwin
is writing before Mendel before the
establishment of genetic laws all true
classification is genealogical that's
his strong claim everything will be
shown to have a kind of heraldic or
narrative connection but he continues
that sentence by emphasizing that the
researchers are unconscious he says the
community of descent is the hidden bond
which naturalist have been
consciously seeking and it goes on the
process of inquiry it seems is accorded
authenticity by here here here by him by
its likeness to the process uncovered is
a very curious rhetorical device so
natural selection is discovered by the
unconscious processes of rumination of
researchers it's a long drawn-out
unconscious set of happenings it's it is
extraordinary I think that he achieved
so much that was vigorous and available
in writing what might appear on the face
of it therefore to be a very dry kind of
history he's setting aside a memory as
not only a sustaining but as a
functional process in evolutionary
history jars against such a long
tradition of sacred values Augustine for
instance delighting in the multiplicity
of memory as a token of the worth of
mankind and of individual identity are
reading what he writes this is in the
confessions what then am i oh my god of
what nature am i a life various and
manifold and exceedingly vast behold in
the numberless holes and caves in the
innumerable fields and dens and caverns
of my memory full without measure of
numberless kinds of things present there
are either through images as all bodies
are or present in the things themselves
as our our thoughts or by some notion or
observation as our emotions are which
the memory retains even though the mind
feels them no longer as long as whatever
is in the memory is also in the mind
through all these I run and fly to and
fro I penetrate into them on this side
and that as far as I can and yet there
is nowhere any end
that wonderful sense of freedom
endlessness intricacy that Agustin
evokes I think is something that Darwin
would deeply sympathise with that
complexity that endlessness because
Darwin actually writes in one of his
notebooks superiority of memory does not
depend on its length many animals as
horses have very long and good memories
but in its multiplicity and the
comparison of ideas a good many people
have commented in indeed I've written
extensively elsewhere on the uneasy
assimilation of the human to other forms
of animal life in Darwin's refusal in
the Origin anywhere to comment
specifically on mankind but just to set
them among the higher animals he saw
this as a diplomatic move as one that
meant that he wasn't it had to confront
religious groups but of course it's
profoundly disturbing because no longer
is the human selected out and made
particular instead we are part of the
rampage of ordinary fruitful life form
and I think it's worth noticing that his
diminishment of memory as capacity and
as interpretive tool is running through
that refusal to select out the human and
I think it does come and as I've
suggested in a rather hidden and laconic
way to cause anguish and creative
resistance I haven't time this morning
to expand on the ways in which it seems
to me that Freud in particular works
with and against this renunciation of
human memory in Darwin and makes out of
it a recuperative system in which health
can only be assured by rediscovering the
grounded basis of human behavior and
human understanding human self-identity
through going back in that ontogeny
phylogeny met
for which likens the single lifespan to
the lifespan of the species darwin's
writing I think it's worth observing and
the organization and the plenitude of
his writing is very like some of the
satisfactions that Augustine has evoked
a sense of the amplitude the variety the
admiration the numberless nests of the
past and the present world
Darwin suggests it's used me
a form of memory for a world that no
human being has ever lived in and he
does it by a lateral largesse of example
exclamation intricate description and
familial ordering I'm not suggesting
that this rhetoric is extrinsic to his
argument but it does in some ways pull
against it and it certainly serves to
solve the loss of memory as a
controlling and activating medium a loss
that is nevertheless crucial to what he
is telling us
Darwin affirmed at every stage of his
argument in examples the linked concepts
of diversification and selection his
metaphors of the tree and the great
family in the origin went some way to
articulate his emphasis on unlike nest
transformation continuity and kinship so
they don't really fall flat together
they haven't got a complete explanatory
fit but there's one thing he does not
face head-on about his theories and this
again seems to me to be connected with
the idea of memory and narrative memory
and history that is the loss of future
plan what he does over and over again is
that it were to prophesy the knowledge
of the past but to refuse to tell
anything about what may come for
instance when we better know the many
means of migration then by the light
which geology now throws and will
continue to throw on former changes of
climate and of the level of the land we
shall surely be unable to trace in an
admirable
the former migrations of the inhabitants
of the whole world who noticed those
shifty tenses there when then surely
understandings going to allow something
which will track former changes nowhere
will heal our glimpses of future forms
and rightly so of course because it's
fundamental to his argument that they
are unforeseen produced out of too many
variables to be plotted in advance
so although Darwin himself gives some
considerable emphasis to the language of
progress and improvement generating an
onward and upward motion in much of his
storytelling these tales are constantly
under the pressure of us not other
darker stories of rapine degradation and
loss I quote him nothing is easier than
to admit in words the truth of the
universal struggle for life or more
difficult at least I have found it so
then constantly to bear this conclusion
in mind we behold the face of nature
bright with gladness we often see super
abundance of food we do not see or we
forget that the birds which are idly
singing around us mostly live on insects
or seeds and are thus constantly
destroying life gladness and destruction
life making and destroying itself the
individual swamped and yet demanded as a
medium for mutation the human everywhere
and nowhere in his argument memory
fundamentally functionally powerless
swore 'td yet stirring in so many
creatures it seems to him beyond the
human and of course essential to the
historians activity darwin's troubling
perceptions were controverted
immediately within his own lifespan by
samuel butler the true progenitor one
may say of the idea of memes in
unconscious memory but also tartly
observed that Darwin seemed to have
forgotten his own predecessors including
his own grandfather's ideas
and had failed to acknowledge their
contribution to his work a neat if nasty
turn on this theme of the loss of memory
the will to revive memory as a
functional part not simply of an
individual's narrative but as intrinsic
to evolutionary history is seen in a
great many other writers both of his
time and later but it very often becomes
an act of mourning and I want to end
just by reading a poem of Thomas Hardy's
because Hardy in his fiction and his
poetry sets the single human lifespan
among the multiple scales of existence
present in any moment the ephemeral the
fossils the buildings passed and gone
the leveled landscape of great antiquity
the grass of the day always epicenter in
Hardy is the figure of the human that
figure which does not simply pass from
youth to age and doth the past because
through memory Hardy conjures various
different ages survive in the person and
not only retrospectively but in the
moment he ends one great poem very
simple one where he looks into the glass
and sees his wasted frame how he still
feels the throbbings of noontide or this
poem called in a museum here he sets
alongside Darwin's work the theories of
Maxwell and Helmholtz the infinitely
distant in time can be juxtaposed then
in the immediate hardy himself was
fascinated by Einstein what he called
his bending ocean of temporality and his
poem takes that up as a kind of comfort
they short mold by the way is both mold
and both kinds of both in a museum
here's the mold of a musical bird long
passed from light which over the earth
before man came was winging
there's a contralto voice I heard last
night that lodges in me still with its
sweep singing such a dream is time that
the COO of this ancient bird has
perished not but his blent or will be
blending mid visionless wilds of space
with the voice that I heard in the full
song of the universe unending that idea
of the full fumed universe an ending of
everything being still in action in the
transformations of energy but rather
than end on that hopeful note which
after all goes against the second law of
thermodynamics I would just like to
remind you that one couldn't also
interpret this question of memory for
Darwin biographically Darwin lost his
mother when he was 8 years old and he
was mortified by an appalling double
loss which was he said that he had
almost no memory of her whatsoever
save for one scene when she was dying
his great enterprise in the origin so
haunting searching for the one
primordial form the great family of
life-forms going beyond individuality
yet needing the individual as the
freight of change all these kinships the
plumbing of irretrievable lost histories
could well I think be read as a form of
reparation and mourning at the same time
it also makes life and accepts
extinction in his argument almost all
past species have vanished most without
trace or the merest fragments of record
and our species almost certainly it will
do so to how Darwin would have rejoiced
at the discovery of DNA with its
demonstration of profound genetic
continuities and individuality
what without sentimentality the
Sharon olds at the end of her 1993
grueling and powerful sequence of poems
the father can call not human love in
the recurrence of feature and the track
of descent but matters love thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much now it's my pleasure
to introduce John W dower who will be
our last speaker this morning last
spring when I was still sitting on
academic council it almost became sort
of weekly routine that Philip Khoury
would come in and announced that John
Bowers book had just won another prize
and and it was you know this prize this
week in the surprise the next week and
there were four or five in a row and
each week he'd come in and be another
prize and finally at the end it was the
Pulitzer Prize for general nonfiction
for embracing defeat I would suggest
that as your homework assignment which
you will thoroughly enjoy that you read
embracing defeat together with American
Scripture as as two books about
democracy and the establishment of
democracy what democracy is as a lived
experience as opposed to a thing a word
a concept and of course it involves
remembering and forgetting and in the
case of Japan after World War two
democracy involved forgetting many other
ideas about Japan a whole framework of
concepts about Japan based on Imperial
Japan I I read somewhere that the
original title or one of the titles John
was thinking of for the book is
reinventing Japan that book was preceded
back in 1986 by the book war without
mercy
subtitled race and power in the Pacific
War because John felt that he needed to
understand as best he could the wartime
experience before writing about the
post-war experience war without mercy
explores the nature of racism on both
sides
in the Pacific War in World War two and
and for jhand our democracy and racism
are two great themes or if you will two
great questions for our times his desire
to understand them as real experiences
and not just things that is to
understand them as they are lived
emotionally even viscerally has led him
to widen the range of materials that he
uses in in his historical work as if you
tried to write a history of MIT the
school even you know bits a history of
student life based on undergraduate
association documents or even if I will
say a history of MIT based on academic
council minutes you're missing a lot and
so John has gotten into arranged
materials like cartoons and songs and
slang expressions to try to get closer
to the real you know thick personal and
collective experience this of course I
think has also to do with an abiding
interest of John's in art and
photography in design in film he worked
for four years in Japan for an
english-language book editor in the
early 60s doing work mainly in design
and art related books and now I'm going
backwards in time he had dropped out of
graduate school to go and live in Japan
for this 4-year period and his
fascination with Japan began earlier
when he went there as a summer adventure
as a student I guess at Amherst at that
time so that was when he first went to
Japan met his wife there as well as met
Japan so I think it's it's a you know
getting back to the sort of this
convergence of of the alumni and the
youth we here at MIT have the privilege
of working with students who are at the
stage of their lives where they thinking
about doing something for the summer or
taking some trip or having some
adventure and it's our privilege to be
able to encourage them
and who knows what will happen 3040
years later John thank you well thank
you very much
when Pauline spoke about going attending
a reunion of people in the Marshall Plan
it reminded me of a visit I made a
several months ago to Washington and Lee
University to give a talk and they put
me up in a very beautiful building I
spent the night sleeping under robert e
lee's portrait and surrounded by the
atmosphere of the history of the south
and I had breakfast the next morning
with an MIT alumni who alumnus who had
been in combat in the Pacific War and
had wanted to get together with me and
he was fascinating he told me stories I
had never heard or known about the the
nature of the Pacific War he told me a
great deal about how his views were
shaped by robert e lee's sense of
chivalry and then he leaned across the
breakfast table and he said to me if you
weren't there you shouldn't be writing
about it
so I said well there goes the Civil War
because but but it is presumptuous in
many ways for us to do these things to
have tried to reconstruct the past as as
historians but uh I I still think we
have to do it and I wanted to touch on
aspects of war in memory of the most
sensitive sought that many of you can
can relate to and I'm sure will relate
to and that is war memories of war and
the intersection of war and memory and
how this public memory and how this has
shaped the way we think and I want to
begin with you in in the infinite
corridor I just want to go back with you
to the infinite corridor where of course
you have two very striking memorials the
first two the MIT students who died in
World War one and perhaps when you are
passing through again you might pause
and read it it's it's the inscription on
the wall reads in memory of the brave
men of the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology who gave their lives in the
Great War uhnot Domini and then the
Roman numerals for 1914 to 1918 under
that is a little quotation only victory
remains and a fame forever secure it's
very poignant to look at that now it's
very poignant to see this because of
course victory didn't remain they had
their momentary victories World War one
was the war to end all wars as they
called it at the time and it of course
led us into the Cataclysm of the mid
19th century and and so you see a sense
of the hope of the times their victory
was very ephemeral a fame forever secure
and that seems very very ironic to us
now also because I think if we look at
those names they're not famous what we
look at is a sense of grievous waste
that somehow we say you know um why did
this happen and so we go back and we
look at this in a different way and of
course as we go back now and look at
World War one the terms we use a pity it
in terms we use a horror because we see
this as the beginning of a new age of
accelerated technological slaughter and
as we go back to wrestle with these
things from our perspective of time we
get into controversial areas so if you
go down now to the Smithsonian
Institution there will be an in the Air
and Space Museum there will be an
exhibit on World War one and and air
power and it's not a positive exhibition
it's the notion that there was here
great heroism in the war but it was also
the beginning of a new age of of
military combat and weaponry that led us
into the great carnage of the 20th
century that we experienced and then you
turn from the World War One inscription
and you on the other wall is the
inscription for the MIT students and who
died in World War two and that reads
simply and and their names under it it
that reads simply in memory of those who
gave their lives 1941 to 1945 and it's
very interesting I know nothing about
the the the history of these
inscriptions there's no sense there's no
brave man as there was in the in the
first inscription there's no great war
which of course was the name of world
war one at the war to end all wars and
there's no sanguine optimistic quotation
there and I think when you look at this
you have a different sense of poignancy
because of course this is world war two
so those people could be sitting here in
the audience today they could be with us
today so immediately we say what would
they have done and when we look at an
inscription like that which moves us I
think many things begin to happen to us
many things are evoked
in us one is the sense that this was a
just war and this was a good war and
these were heroic deaths and we can we
can identify their sacrifice very
clearly with the defeat of fascism the
defeat of Nazism the defeat of Japanese
aggression and militarism and so we have
a real sense of the good war in very
real ways which is not a concept that
we're able to use very much with wars
anymore and then I think because we're
in MIT and because we think in these
ways we think about the legacies of the
world we move from this simple
inscription to the legacies of world war
ii because it did change our our lives
in ways we are still coming to grips
with this is the emergence of the
post-war national security state
it's the emergence of something we
hadn't seen before and which governs our
lives which is the military industrial
university complex not just military
industrial but the way in which we have
come together it's the emergence of a
world of international organizations and
and you can pursue this in many many
ways as we go back to look not simply at
the war experience itself but what it
gave to us but if you think of today 19
the year 2000 one of the very
interesting things happening today is
how many things are coming out now about
world war ii that we didn't know that
have been coming out over the years and
no matter where you look these issues of
world war ii of very profound issues
with us today and they shape the way we
think about the war and they shaped our
ideologies and they shape our politics
today and there's no way you can turn if
of course we have to hold debates on the
you know the Holocaust in memory and
practice if you any of you saw the New
York Times today there's a remarkable
article on the reconsideration of
resistance to Nazism in in Nazi Germany
today all that's going on in Germany
because the great debates over how much
you should acknowledge
after World War two people who were
communists who had resisted Hitler and
and and organized resistance and how
many of these people were suppressed in
memory in West Germany and elevated in
memory in East Germany and how we can
speak about them more clearly now why
because we know more we have the records
of Stasi and East German records we have
the Soviet archives and Alma open so we
have perspectives on these things
we now talk about Swiss neutrality in
the Swiss banks why didn't we talk about
that earlier we talk about the some of
the myths of the French Resistance or
the other side being the collaboration
of the French and others in the
Holocaust and many other countries
collaborated and all the cost and all of
these things are coming up now we
certainly have always known how heroic
through the Soviet Union was in the war
and they took as many Americans forget
the heaviest losses by far and world
walk to China was close perhaps but
enormous losses but we now are doing
more scholarship on the atrocities of
the Soviet armies on both the Eastern
Front and against Hitler and then later
against the Japanese and when you turn
to the area I work on with concerning
Japan we've just learned over the years
enormous number of Japanese atrocities
and terrible things that we didn't know
about we didn't talk about before we
know about some people knew now the
responsibility of the Emperor of Japan
we decided we wish to keep him Emperor
and so we said we won't investigate this
and this was decided without any serious
investigation the terrible activities a
very scientific of of Japan's unit 731
which was the unit that conducted lethal
experiments it's the closest thing to a
Holocaust planned lethal experiments on
prisoners of war and hopping and areas
of Manchurian killed about 3,000 people
the comfort women is a huge issue now
and extraordinarily volatile women who
were forced to provide sexual services
to the Japanese and today as a historian
my the calls I get from the media and
from lawyers now concerned slave labor
of American POWs by Japanese companies
these are the calls I get today why are
they coming out now it's over half
century later and why are they coming
out now when America occupied Japan from
1945 to 1950 - it wasn't a sovereign
country we could demand any information
we wanted we could pursue prosecutions
and it came out because a lot of the
cover-up was American and Japanese so we
get into Cold War considerations why
were things buried why they were buried
for political reasons they came up and
they come up now and so history was
distorted in various ways well if I look
at the world war ii memorial in the
infinite corridor i left not one legacy
of course and that is the nuclear legacy
with which the war ends and then then my
mind and i think all our minds go to
another memorial another list of names
another kind of memory and of course we
thought the hero humor and the types of
commemorations and how the war is
remembered in japan they built their
peace Museum in Hiroshima in 1995 and
they have been keeping records of the
names of the victims of the bombs now
this is a very difficult area very
controversial how many people were
killed and so on but this is fraught
with it's taken us years to work at it
we don't have it clear and now it's
become very politicized of the Japanese
initially made memorials and talked
about the Japanese dead from Hiroshima
and from and Nagasaki and the nuclear
bombs it was only after enormous
struggle that you could get into
consciousness the fact that there were
thousands and thousands of Koreans
killed in those bombs
and their names and they were not
memorialized because we're seen as a
Japanese thing till finally you now have
memorials to the Koreans and now
something very different is happening in
Japan which is bizarre and complicated
and I can't go into it but if you were a
survivor of Hiroshima you would be
called a hibachi our person who suffered
the bombing and as time passed those
people get benefits in Japan health
benefits Special Investigations and so
on so it used to be a stigma to be a
debauch shah but now it has certain
concrete benefits so people get a car to
say they are a hibachi Sean it is a is
it something desirable so many people
wish to have the cons whenever they die
in Japan now they are inscribed in the
rackets in hiroshima and nagasaki as
deceased he boxes deceased Ibaka shop so
suddenly we're having huge numbers of
deaths for people who are dying from
ordinary illnesses old people and so the
numbers are becoming very complex and
once again history and memory and the
way these things are used are becoming
very complex now but then of course when
I bring you well we wove into the place
like a Hiroshima in memory but we get
into great questions which which excite
and people very very powerfully of was
this right was it wrong was it a war
crime and you get into very complex
debates just to give you an example a
very famous distinguished influential
Japanese conservative very conservative
man who was the head of the equivalent
of the AMA American Medical Association
Japanese Medical Association had man
named Takumi who had been a nuclear
physicist during the war was very highly
placed in court circles and in
scientific circles then went on to
become a doctor he's very conservative
man wrote in an article he is later
saying in his view Hiroshima was
necessary they were they were too
stubborn they wouldn't have
I surrendered but Nagasaki was a war
crime because they didn't wait so if the
issues are out there they're very
complex they're much more complex than
simple issues now in Japan what happens
when you take something like Hiroshima
Nagasaki at this historical event is
memory it doesn't lead so much to
anti-americanism that a budget lays led
to is this profound sense of horror of
horrors of war the real horrors of war
and so you emerge out of this with the
notion no more Hiroshima and you have a
sense of that Japan must be a leader in
anti-nuclear ISM so where is the war led
us on one side to an arms race and the
sense of deterrence and all sorts of
complex theories here you have the same
thing being used to say this should be
stopped this should be suppressed
no more Hiroshima becomes a than a use
of history that goes from Japan to the
entire world what does this do
politically in the country well whereas
the man I talked to at Washington and
Lee is talking about his combat and
these atrocious Japanese he was fighting
the Japanese are looking and Hiroshima
becomes a way of almost of erasing
everything that occurred before
Hiroshima so you forget what your pan
did and you talk about how Japan was
victimized and it's a very strong image
of victimization but if you take the
concept of victimization it moves in
various directions one is to say they
will never do this again so it feeds
anti-militarist ik anti-war sentiment
the other is you forget how you
victimized others you forget how you
were victimized or in the same people
person community can be both victim and
victimizer and so these get very very
complicated and we begin to see these
complex uses of history now then I'm if
you move from this what you have is the
issue of remembering and forgetting it's
like photographs historical photographs
you have physical historical photographs
of famous people in the past
jeferson home ever and that's what they
become we thought of they're ingrained
and there's always George Washington
he's always facing in the same direction
and we we don't see them younger we
don't see them in different
circumstances and this is similar with
what we remember because what we
remember involves what we don't choose
to bring to the surface so we're into
remembering and forgetting and and we
talked a lot about this with Japan and
and a couple of years ago a number of
years ago I I was asked to talk about
war memory in Japan and it was in
Washington DC I went down and in the
evening before the talk for the first
time I went to see another war memorial
Vietnam War Memorial I had not seen it
before and what I would of course this
then trig is a whole new way of thinking
about things because who cannot be moved
and what incidentally we're doing in
these walls is bringing the abstract
discussions of war and these issues down
to the human level suddenly we realize
what we're doing who cannot be moved by
the wall and so I I look at the wall and
I'm profoundly moved as everyone is you
move very very slowly to zero when on a
certain name for some reason and then I
step back and I say this is but it's
also a figurative wall because there
were millions of other dead people
there's no Asians there's no others this
is the perfect example of victim
consciousness and it's the natural
response but it also blinds us or it's
blocks off seeing something else and it
also has very profound political
implications because of course America
doesn't want to commit itself to any war
now where we will lose American fighting
men that is a use of this history so
we're moving in in many many different
directions we have here now no more Viet
Nam's which may mean many things to
different people too but it certainly
mean something to policymakers as well
and so history is being used again to
remember to forget to remember
selectively it was the Vietnam water to
get personal while I had dropped out of
school for quite a while and came back
in 1965 to be a graduate student in
Japanese literature I was not doing
history and it was the Vietnam War that
in fact had a profound impact on my own
way of looking because I was I was
working on Japan I has lived in Japan
and I 1965 it's 20 years after the war
and you look at the abnormal you say the
planes are coming from Japan Japan is
our ally in this war 20 years later
after this horrendous war in the Pacific
these are our allies the basis of their
we're now fighting another Asian country
but this is the second time because it
already had started in the Korean War in
1950 five years after that earlier war
we were using Japan as our ally five
years after the World War two China was
now our enemy who had been our ally how
do these things happen and and I I felt
at this point that this that a humanist
a historian a social scientist perhaps
should try to understand these things
this was the way to get at it so I went
ended now it is true the man in in
Virginia is absolutely correct it is
presumptuous of me to say what his
experience is like but I can go back I
think we can and say we can look here we
have no questions to ask we have new
documents we have new materials just as
Pauline finds materials that secret
documents things that have become
Declassified later new perspectives new
a comparative approaches now I could I
could move on with you through many many
other memorials and ways of talking
about this because we're taking a very
similar thing but we're now moving in
different directions of Holocaust
commemorations huge struggles who will
be included in the Holocaust Museum who
will not not simple simple issues we can
go to places like Pittsburgh where
President Reagan made his notorious
visit how was history
used at this occasion where he visited a
cemetery with Nazi graves as well as as
their victims and and something we could
go on very much is what's going on in
China the People's Republic of China the
great issue now an enormous Lee complex
Rape of Nanking now if you go to The
Rape of Nanking Memorial in China though
there's two things to keep in mind it
wasn't built until the 1980s for decades
Chinese didn't talk about Nanking it
wasn't part of their consciousness they
had so much on their minds it was a very
complex that was a very late Memorial
wider to come up when it did but when
you walk to the MOU more one of the
great things we don't know a lot of but
there was a rape of Nanjing there was a
horrendous Japanese atrocity one of the
things we have no idea of is the real
scale of it all the numbers and so if
you are a denier like a whole Japanese
equivalent of a Holocaust denier you go
at someone's numbers and say they can't
possibly be true you always have to be
careful with numbers because they're
always inflated in the victim
consciousness rhetoric and then others
can come in and attack the numbers where
the substance may be correct if you go
to the Memorial and Nanking the first
thing you see as you're approaching it
carved into the wall is the numbers in
Arabic numbers 300,000 it's literally
carved in stone and I once asked a
Japanese scholar who was associated with
it to could we do work where they would
say where they got the numbers because
this was so controversial he says we
know what that's beyond question refused
to say where to come well let's become a
number that's now inflated others say
400 the Japanese go in and say the right
wing and says that can't be true
and they get debating on these numbers
but land King has become part of
politics now it's very complex part of
politics
it's a kaleidoscope and I could go on
and look around I want to I don't want
to do that I want to just tell you about
one final way of thinking about the war
I haven't seen this it's the Okinawa War
Memorial World War two ended with the
terrible Battle of Okinawa in which the
Japanese army basically was wiped out
about a hundred thousand people about a
third of the island of Okinawa died
about a hundred two hundred fifty
thousand civilians in Okinawa died
mericans took enormous casualties the
Japanese High Command and the military
the military the High Command and the
Emperor of Japan whom we later said had
no responsibility wanted that battle as
a warning to the Americans not to invade
Japan that they would have to cut a deal
will show them how hard we can fight so
they basically the Japanese sacrificed a
quarter million people and they were
killing their own people our soldiers
were killing civilians it's a horrendous
image of war the governor a former
governor of Okinawa man named OTO was 15
years old at the time of the battle and
what's one of the young boys drafted
into the war and his dream was to take
something like Vietnam War Memorial
where you remembered what war was but to
make it for every participant in the war
and he's done it and I haven't been
there but there is a memorial now in in
Okinawa which has the names of the
Japanese dead as the names of the
Okinawan debt has the names of the
American debt as the names of Koreans
who may have been fighting and every one
he could possibly find and I look at
that or I think about it or I thought
about it from here and it's very
possible that some of the names on the
wall in the infinite corridor and are
out there too because there must have
been MIT people who died there but we're
in a different world now I think we were
seeing this he's using this as a very
strong piece statement he's using this
as an anti Emperor statement anti the
the Japan that has turned open our into
a military base for the American
statement so once again we see the
intersection of history and memory in
profound ways
the memorial doesn't tell us
how this came about or what to do but
that I think is the responsibility we
have as social scientists and humanists
and historians to try to figure it out
I'm not sure we can but that's why I
disagreed with the man in Virginia that
was something we shouldn't be doing
I want to add that the I think you could
have heard a pin drop for the last 20
minutes but I want to add that the event
we're celebrating here is not
unconnected to what John has been
talking about in the words of my friend
Tom Hughes the war really messed up the
minds of Engineers as scientists it
convinced them that the education of
engineers and scientists had to be broad
because look at the effect that they had
in civilization at large in the war at
large and at MIT I'm convinced that it
led to the decision to review MIT
education and in 1950 to broaden it with
the establishment of this school you
know it's almost 11:30 and I almost hate
to open up for discussion because I
think we could have a full hour at least
I you know I what was that a mandate to
cram in as much as we can in five
minutes
question first make a comment I was
sitting here my mind went a few things
like survival of the fittest but when
you discuss memory immediately to my
mind comes the fact of what's so
prominent here at MIT now the
neurosciences and everything that's
happening recently and and I ask myself
is there any molecular biologist or
neuroscientist who has owned in on as
you have on his work and related to his
ideas of memory and that's my question
but I go on to say that I was searching
my mind
somebody must have written that book or
done that workers began it and all I
could think of was Dawkins book on The
Selfish Gene and the genes search for
immortality that's the cliche I think
away from that but basically it's made a
lot of difference to me in the thinking
of our genes search for survival and the
fact that at least in a simplistic way
is he explained it that we're the host
and and as others have throughout
history and what their attention is to
survive and we all have some green
allergy in us and so forth and but the
question is has anybody done that
Steve yeah there is an interesting
connection among these things because
human memory is in itself a Darwinian
adaptation and some of its limitations
are because it wasn't designed as a VCR
just to record things as they happened
but in the service of probably a lot of
needs including the need to look good
and to look consistent and to furnish
your own image and so on the only person
that I know who's tried that with Darwin
himself is Robert Wright in the moral
animal where every other chapter is a
biography of Darwin from the point of
view of the evolutionary analysis of
personality and memory trying to show
how some of Darwin's decisions and I
think how some of Darwin's memories may
have been shaped by the the human urge
to burnish your image post-hoc make
yourself look good after if the events
have happened and I think there is
obviously enormous space for more
thinking about these other aspects of
Darwinian inheritance for example I mean
in primatology
one of the things he did was he recorded
the first year of one of his children's
lives in great detail in a diary and I
what I was wanting today was really to
bring back to our memories the
extraordinary creativity the way in
which this is not a man who had one idea
and thought he could solve human history
with it but somebody who is always
ranging off in different directions but
I can't answer the precise question
because I don't know of any book that
does quite what you're asking perhaps
I'll try
[Applause]
one question I have I guess it's more
for Pauline than the others but they all
might deal with it it was Pauline's use
of the word myth
now one meaning of the word myth that we
all use is equivalent to untruth
but there's another meaning of myth
which is very important in history where
myth is a kind of figurative or
metaphoric creation not a literal one
and the myth of the Declaration of
Independence to me is an extremely
important part of our history and when
Lincoln called it in the Gettysburg
Address called Jefferson's statement
about equality the proposition on which
this nation was founded that is
empirically untrue but mythically very
important and I'd like to believe that
it's a truth we're still trying to
realize we comment on that oh I agree
it's part of the reinterpretation of the
document by subsequent generations I the
meaning that that came to incarnate the
meaning of equality in the Revolution is
is in some ways bizarre since there's so
many other more specific expressions and
then its original meaning was so limited
it real it really in the Declaration
refers to the state of nature that
nobody is subject to another person
before government is created and that
all legitimate authority comes from
consent our equality means so much more
than that in an established nation has
so many more expressions that that be
that that that statement came to
incarnate all those other ideas is in
some ways remarkable and it happened
over time it become it becomes the truth
as people embrace it and and make it a
statement of our national identity I
think you're absolutely correct but it's
a creation over time not at one minute
in time and what is so interesting about
that about
Lincoln's writings on the topic is that
he simply said Jefferson meant it to be
that in the beginning and that's where
error and this sort of organizing
iconographic myth coexist we have the
tendency to want to disaggregate those
you know to explain it and and what I
discovered this tremendous hostility
toward anyone who tries to do that even
if you know don't we need these myths
don't we want to believe this is what
what was always meant that the founders
had in their minds what we see in the
document is it so problematic to say
that it wasn't all there at the
beginning that it was put there over
time it seems to be for many people well
that's right
it's the woman in Philadelphia don't we
need these myths and I have to confess
I've been reflecting on that ever since
I don't have a question I have a comment
a member of the class of 54 so I entered
MIT in 1950 when this program originated
and I really want to thank the founders
very much because over the years and I
think that it expanded my horizon and
maybe more importantly my curiosity and
deeply enriched my life but his analysis
of those facts probably changed very
very greatly by his later experiences
and readings and interactions with
others during his life so we assume that
historians say coming later in time
viewing facts earlier can reinterpret
those facts without the biases of the
people of contemporary times but the
historians of later times themselves
come with their own indeed two steps
inside so isn't the historian really in
the in the situation
in Myrtle theorem namely we have a
system in which we can state
propositions but we can't be certain or
all to be false in other words is the
historian writing history today any
closer to the truth than the historian
writing history fifty years ago was when
they were writing it contemporaneously
and can the historian ever escape the
dilemma I think I'll turn to the
historians once tempted to start with
another great unanswerable question what
is truth I think historians are very
uncomfortable with the whole idea of
truth I mean the pervasive ideas that
history is constructed that is it's put
together at you know and in response to
the needs every given time I'm not
altogether comfortable with that I I
think that although historians don't
like the uncomfortable with truth they
certainly believe in accuracy and they
they certainly understand the existence
of error it's sort of like having a
devil without a god just one imply the
other I don't know and I in some ways I
think we are capable of putting together
histories that are fuller because as
John said you know we we have more
documents we get more documents one of
my colleagues Gordon what it Brown says
we know more about events than those who
lived through them because we have a
broader perspective an individual has
one perspective we can gather many more
it's a different kind of a truth there
is there can be a greater accuracy to
the stories we tell but that these are
enduring and determinative forever I
don't think any of us have this I once
wrote in the New York Times I remember
in a review that history is is a battle
against an Akron is
and I think it's the anachronisms in our
sources the anachronisms in ourselves
I hadn't meant to make a profound
statement but I do remember having
somebody I could this to me as I walked
all the next but I think we we try
always to distill those out we're never
entirely successful but I think the war
is meaningful John
well you're right a very distinguished
British historian eh cop said study this
historian before you study what he
writes because in other words well but
that's it's a reasonable question he's
you ask questions out of your own time
and and you ask different questions of
the past no this is very healthy that we
asked was different kinds of questions
of the past and I think what has
happened in history I think the history
that we're doing now is richer and more
diversified than the history in the past
for example when I was a graduate
student in the 60s and 70s we were still
in a stage where history was very much
histories of a leads it was very formal
you studied the official documents you
worked with a leads you worked with a
certain types of published materials
what we do now is we want to know other
things of the past we want to know
popular culture women were basically
excluded women's history feminist
history has given us a whole new areas
to look at we we look at popular
cultures we and we look at a whole
series of questions that we never
thought of asking before and at the same
time this leads us to treating different
materials as text so the concept of the
very concept what is a text has changed
the text used to be a formal written
document and usually a very official
type of document you did not I remember
when I was a young teacher so we're
talking in the in the early 70s
had a student who did a very imaginative
study of the socialization of the mêlée
leads in Japan he went into their course
room curriculum spread their yearbooks
found out who are these people who are
becoming the leaders of Japan and I got
a call from someone saying do you really
regard this as serious these materials
he's just reading they're popsicle I
regardless we now recognize that these
popular materials are interesting you
didn't write histories based on
bestsellers you wrote history based on
great books but what were the general
people thinking I think that
quantitative historians have given no
sense of using data to check assertions
that other people have it doesn't mean
that there weren't great historians in
the past but and then just the the type
of materials we now have access to in
the United States we have access to a
lot of materials on the other hand which
we didn't get into we also are closed
off from very basic materials like the
CIA records or other top-level materials
that we can't get at in Japan there are
all sorts of materials we can't get out
but on the other hand the KGB and the
Stasi of open their files so we are
seeing things so I do think that you
read the books that are being written
now and then some of the great books of
the past but there are things now that
do indeed encourage us to say where
we're it's a moving target we're
vulnerable to our the questions we ask
you have to be sensitive that you're
asking certain questions why do you ask
this question the question but but but I
think that if you're sensitive to that
it there has been great progress this
stuff the materials coming out now are
fascinating in ways that we didn't have
in the past they're just about things we
didn't talk about in the past and
they're interesting to us because the
questions also come out of contemporary
preoccupations which raises again the
whole problem of of anachronism is as if
your interest in given areas if it comes
out of canoe coming out of contemporary
politics almost predicts what your
allows me to find and I have to say I
confess to I experienced a rather gross
example of
I am Minh salting a new series it's
going to be on Franklin and Benjamin
Franklin the television series and I had
a letter from a producer that said that
the funders had hoped that we could
emphasize Franklin as a champion of
diversity this is a guy that hated
having Germans come to Pennsylvania and
his whole demographic theory was based
on a concept that you didn't need to
have anybody but Englishmen because if
they moved into a space they just
multiply till they filled it so why did
you want these swarthy skin people's
like like Germans and Swedes I mean you
know it's it's a very interesting
perspective because you understand the
difference weigh race was perceived at
different times but hey a champion of
diversity I just don't think we can give
you in bed right Roz Williams mentioned
the Italian futurist who flourished
around 1900 and they were artists and
there were architects and they wish to
destroy Venice because Venice was
congeal memory and carried values in its
architecture in its physical
manifestations and now go to John Gallin
and ask him a question I don't know
whether you probably did realize it but
I noted how often you mentioned physical
objects you've referred to the carvings
on the wall and then you refer to
monuments and also the tombstones and I
want to ask you how seriously do you
take physical objects as congeal memory
in its expressions of history that
constantly remind us
of the past was this accidental all the
mentioning of the physical of was this
because of we at MIT which is an
Institute of Technology well I was using
physical objects simply because it's
such a complicated topic I thought I
could move easily with that as as really
a small way in which to talk about this
I do think that we make certain objects
iconic and we look at them whether it's
the Declaration of Independence or the
Enola Gay we put it up there and then we
make this a symbol of certain things so
that I think in the broader sense the
the much of the way in which public
memory is structured is in physical
forms and this is one of the great
debates now is what do you have in your
museums what do you have in your
exhibitions and this is a very very
controversial area but it also is a very
wide-open area if you go if you take my
kind of physical objects this is very
important Museum at Hiroshima is very
important and you understand I think you
can indeed move to these larger issues
through a very discrete object and and
how these are interpreted how they are
displayed how they are presented is is
very very important at the time of the
1995 on the great controversy over the
Enola Gay emerged and how this would be
displayed in Washington I was very
struck by the different uses of objects
the Americans were using the Enola Gay
as a symbol of American power and the
end of a horrendous war and you had this
gigantic monstrous impressive airplane
the Japanese icon that was put against
that was the lunchbox of us of a young
girl who had disappeared in the bomb
that all they ever found was the lunch
box with carbonated rice in it
and this is this is the icon in Japan
when they brought this icon to the
exhibit in Washington people were very
upset because they said their lunch box
is more powerful than the super fortress
and missus this has thrown things out of
out of balance and I do think that the
way in which these physical objects like
the walls with names on them are just
stunning because we have much of the
work we've done as social scientists and
that has been very broad Megadeth's and
big grant numbers to suddenly come back
to the name the actual name of the
person in the order in which we knew
they died or something like that is an
extraordinary way of bringing us back to
reality but what it isn't that you have
to hook it to this but there it's so
very vivid to work from the graphic
image to the idea or from the concrete
story or image to the grant theory
rather than from the theory down to that
and I think that's very important but
but there were so many other myths and
that we could have talked about the myth
of the frontier you know the myth of so
many other American myths but the
concrete object is is extraordinary and
bringing point about texts that is
writing which immediately takes you
inside the mind of another person who
may be very distant from you in history
or in time but where you can watch in
the silences between sentences in the
skew of syntax the difficulties often
and the achievements of a mind at work
an individual mind at work and I think
that was something Pauline touched on in
the idea of revision so that literary
historians which is more what I am and
other historians are working with made
objects and with text objects and each
of these kinds of inscription gives us
access to very specific knowledge as
well as to general theory I'm gonna take
one more question there was a lady who
had her hand up and I regret having to
cut off the
recession but if I don't I think it will
shortchange the second afternoon session
and so I apologize please I was very
happy to discover that a George
Washington didn't chop down the cherry
tree because I never believed it anyway
but and the question I have is what what
is happening in the new discoveries
about history in terms of filtering down
to children they are given so much via
the media in this country
what is filtering down to them and how
are their books are their teachers being
brought up to date I really care about
that in any direct way because I don't
go into those schools but one of the
most gratifying things to do in the kind
of history we do is to be invited to
talk to the seminars of secondary school
teachers and they are terrific I never
can understand how they can carry that
teaching schedule I'm like you know I
get exhausted with one class every other
day or something and I I think they're
very heroic they're really heroic
but there are many things I did a summer
seminar in Boulder
people came in for several weeks working
on post-war Japan and I kicked it off
and they brought in lots of academics
and it's very practically oriented how
is our work of interest to you and how
can you present this to your students in
the classroom I'm doing one in New York
in a couple of weeks where it's an
audience and Pauline has done the same
audience with the Morgan Library
hundreds of New York secondary school
teachers and the Social Sciences are
brought in to talk to people to say how
can your work be brought in accessible
ways to our students and I admire this
very much because they're they're really
trying to keep abreast of a broad range
of things but our task is then to say
what can you use to bring it to them and
that's when you get into very concrete
things you know you pass on children's
books from Japan at a certain time or
you pass on graphic materials and how
can you bring them in to appreciate
these complex things we do with I think
that's really very serious attempt on
the part of many secondary many
secondary schools to bring this in our
task is that we tend to much of our
discipline has has moved into jog and
that is so highly technical and
inaccessible that we're really talking
to a small group many of us and the
challenges to get the academic to try to
to speak enly to this broader audience
never speaking to a Superintendent of
Education whatever his title was in New
Jersey and I said I don't think
historians have been very helpful to you
and he said no they're not and he was he
was trying to put together a program for
the schools in his state that was
heavily based on primary documents which
are wonderful teaching vehicles and and
he was having he was a really an uphill
road I like John loved working with
students whatever I with with teachers
because there's they're so dedicated
they're so thirsty they're so
intelligent and you just never have you
have a sense that your your work what
you say will trickle down into their
classrooms and it's it's immensely
gratifying but I said that the people we
see are just an extraordinarily small
elite group of the great troops of
schoolteachers what I read about the
materials that are used in particularly
primary schools is most discouraging
that they are now written largely from a
political point of view that different
groups who are involved say what they
want to have said and that that's how
the history is written this is based
mainly on that long story that was in
the New York Review of Books by
historian a club you would reviewed a
series of text books and actually spoke
with me about this I think there is a
movement away from this there's a
there's an effort to develop
better materials for use in the schools
how far it's going to go I don't know of
course the other problem is that they
don't really teach history in the
schools you know the social sciences
have kind of taken over so the kids sit
around and as one of my students once
said chew the rag about the problems of
democracy having no idea what it is or
where it came from you know having
having no grounding for for their
discussions and it's a great loss I
think history sells properly taught
sells very well because it's about
stories kids like stories that's how
human beings make sense of their
experiences through stories and now we
tell some of us tell stories thank you
so much please join me in
[Applause]